This video is sponsored by Dashlane.
Quickly and securely fill your passwords free
for 30 days with the link in the description.
In the past four decades, natural disasters
have killed 60,000 people, on average, a year.
This includes things like earthquakes, droughts,
epidemics, and fires, although, of course,
not all disasters are equally memorable.
Researchers have found that to get the same
amount of media attention, a famine must kill
38,000 people, while a drought only has to
kill 2,400, an epidemic 1,600, and a volcano
eruption, just 1.
To catch the most eyes, a catastrophe should
be shocking, scary, ongoing, and, most of
all, uncertain.
The Coronavirus, or COVID-19, as it’s officially
known, ticks all these boxes, and then some:
the threat is invisible to the naked eye,
deadly, foreign, and changing every day.
Here’s what we know: Although the number
has since grown, at 120,000 confirmed cases,
there were about 4,300 deaths, giving it an
estimated fatality rate of 3.6%, significantly
lower than SARs, at about 9.5%, or MERs, at
34%.
Although, we also know this number highly
depends on where and who you are.
Cardiovascular disease, high blood sugar,
and chronic respiratory disease, for example,
greatly increase your chance of death.
Even more significant is your age.
The fatality rate drops to just 0.1% for 10-19
year-olds, and remains less than half a percentage
point for anyone under 50.
After that, the odds rapidly deteriorate.
From 1.3% for those in their 50s, to 3.6%
for 60s, 8% for 70s, and 14.8% for anyone
older.
The vast majority, about 80% of those infected,
experience mild to moderate symptoms - most
commonly fever, dry cough, and/or exhaustion
- and then recover, many, on their own and
some without even knowing.
And because these symptoms are so common,
the most minor of cases likely aren’t reported
to authorities, which may make the fatality
rate appear far worse than it truly is.
That, in fact, is also the biggest challenge:
A low fatality rate for the young and healthy
makes it very easy to spread, which comes
at the expense of more vulnerable groups.
The incubation period is estimated anywhere
from 1 to 14 days.
If this is true, those infected may spread
the virus, undetected, most likely by coughs
and sneezes, although it can also be found
in blood, stool, and tears, for one or even
two weeks without knowing they have it.
Scarier than everything we know combined,
though, is everything we don’t.
It’s not yet understood where it originated,
who first contracted it, which animal transmitted
it, or even how, exactly, it began.
Although the first cases were initially linked
to a Wuhan seafood market, later analysis
has cast doubt on this theory.
These large gaps in our understanding leave
considerable room for anyone to fill as they
wish.
Thus, the wide range of reactions: Depending
on where you look, you will either see warnings
that the situation is far worse than reported
and may eventually kill hundreds of thousands
or pleas to remain calm and comparisons to
the seasonal flu.
Until recently, about 80% of all confirmed
cases were located in Mainland, China,
Meaning about 80% of what we know is based
on information provided by that one source.
Which version someone is inclined to believe,
therefore, is largely a litmus test of how
much he or she trusts China.
There’s little doubt that once its leadership
was committed, China acted incredibly quickly,
making decisions that would be layered with
bureaucracy elsewhere.
Famously, China seized the spotlight as an
opportunity to demonstrate its political effectiveness
on the world stage, swiftly converting universities,
convention centers, and schools into makeshift
hospitals.
According to a New York Times estimate, over
700 million Chinese have been simultaneously
quarantined - a feat that requires an unthinkable
degree of both political and cultural solidarity.
It’s state-owned telecoms collected travel
records of every phone in the country, enabling
checkpoints to quickly deny access to high-risk
individuals.
In that same spirit of national brand-building,
Chinese diplomats have given over 400 media
interviews, published over 300 articles, and
the city of Shanghai sent 500,000 face masks
to the center of the South Korean outbreak.
China has tried to disassociate itself from
the outbreak, suggesting it may have originated
elsewhere.
It’s also repeatedly congratulated itself
for slowing its spread, which it argues would
be far worse if not for its diligent work.
What can’t be overlooked, however, is the
phrase “Once its leadership was committed”.
Too often journalists fall into the trap of
either only celebrating China’s operational
efficiency or fixating on its authoritarian
pitfalls.
Clearly, the same top-down system responsible
for building a hospital in 10 days also incentivized
local government officials to suppress crucial
early information about the virus and prioritize
party loyalty above immediate human suffering.
Its genuinely-impressive successes exist in
the context of failures like the example of
Wuhan-based doctor Li Wenliang.
On December 30th, over a week before the first
confirmed death, Li sent a message in a private
doctors’ WeChat group warning of a new SARs-like
outbreak.
Just hours later, 8 doctors from the group,
including Li, were arrested by Wuhan Police
for spreading rumors and disrupting social
order, as announced by the Chinese National
Health Commission.
After being compelled to sign a document admitting
his alleged crimes, Li heroically returned
to work, where he would contract and die from
the very virus he tried to stop.
While his story is particularly tragic, it’s
only made exceptional by his personal sacrifice.
The forces which tried to stop him are sadly,
not.
For every rare example of bravery, there are
undoubtedly countless more scared into silence.
And if even doctors must be this devoted to
the party, there’s only more reason to doubt
government-compiled data.
If numbers were misreported, outright fabricated,
or even just poorly or hastily collected,
they could drastically skew global measures
like fatality and infection rate.
Thus, the large discrepancy of these numbers
between countries.
On March 6th, the U.S. had a reported fatality
rate of 5.9%, while South Korea reported 0.6.
What these numbers obscure, are the number
of people tested.
America’s number, for example, was based
on a pathetic then-239 identified cases and
14 deaths, to Korea’s then-6,593 and 42.
The lesson of this chart is that the easiest
way to maintain a low infection rate is simply
not to test for it - something the U.S. has
thus far excelled at - up until recently making
test kits inaccessible to anyone not exposed
to a confirmed case or having recently traveled
to an infected region.
South Korea, on the other hand, had tested
8,000 people prior to its first case on January
20th.
The next week, it would go on to test 82,000
people across the country.
By making this process easy, like with drive-through
stations, it was able to screen about 10,000
people every single day.
The most dangerous kind of misinformation,
therefore, aren’t crazy claims about fake
cures, which are easily exposed and dispelled,
but the treating of reported data as infallible,
which creates unnecessary alarm in some places
and a dangerous sense of comfort in others.
In truth, everything except the very basics
should be viewed with some degree of skepticism.
By the time you’re watching this video,
the situation may have changed, and many of
these numbers may no longer be accurate.
At the same time, it’s important not to
panic.
While it’s true that so much is unknown,
the precautions are simple and straightforward.
This is the paradox of the Coronavirus: Although
the medical solutions are simple - the World
Health Organization recommends washing your
hands with soap and water or an alcohol-based
sanitizer, regularly, and not touching your
face - stopping the virus is not easy.
In practice, no government on Earth can effectively
manage and guarantee the compliance of every
one of its citizens - especially in democracies
where government power is limited.
While the virus appears to be waning domestically,
in China, it’s entered a distinct second
phase of international spread, to Italy, Iran,
France, Germany, Spain, the U.S., and elsewhere.
In the absence of the tight control made impossible
at this scale, which countries succeed in
containing their outbreaks largely depends
on their level of public trust.
A good point of comparison are the cases of
Hong Kong and Singapore - two places with
similar population sizes, climates, and international
exposure.
At first glance, Hong Kong would seem to be
at far greater risk, with 13 border crossings
to mainland China while Singapore is three
and a half thousand kilometers away.
Even today, in response to the virus, three
crossings remain open in Hong Kong, while
Singapore became one of the first countries
to deny entry to all PRC-passport holders
and anyone who’s been to the mainland in
the past 14 days.
Its government was quick to distribute masks
- 4 for every household, whereas Hong Kong
faced shortages, during which long lines formed
outside pharmacies for hours, as customers
waited for new shipments.
In Singapore, self-employed quarantined residents
and holders of work passes are given about
70 U.S. dollars a day, along with free medical
treatment, to incentivize good behavior.
Those who break quarantine laws are fined
up to about $7,200 USD and face as much as
six months of jail time.
Authorities in Hong Kong, on the other hand,
began the crisis with little to no public
trust, and only lost more after its slow closing
of the border and failure to procure masks.
Its quarantine-breaking punishments were weak,
resulting in several confirmed breaches.
Worse, this often well-deserved distrust spirals
into a self-propelling panic.
Because Hong Kongers didn’t believe their
government could or would protect them, the
most panicked began hoarding supplies, fearing
they might run out.
Everyone else followed suit in a dangerous
game of musical chairs.
And when the music stops, it’s most often
vulnerable groups, like doctors, the disabled,
and the poor who lose.
It’s also worth noting however, that Hong
Kong’s wide-spread distrust predisposed
its residents to take matters into their own
hands, creating a more vigilant public.
A more severe example is Iran, where extreme
suspicion of government has resulted in an
outright crisis, inescapable by even the highest
levels of authority.
This pattern has repeated time and time, and
time, again, anywhere trust is low.
The lesson, repeated but never absorbed, with
SARs, Ebola, MERs, and now today, is that,
while the problem is a medical one for scientists
to research, and develop treatments for, the
suffering is most often self-inflicted.
The actions of people and governments make
the difference between calm and chaos.
After the virus is contained, its treatment
or vaccine, hopefully, discovered, and the
media moves on to more shocking stories, we
must not forget how much was preventable.
Otherwise, the same forces and incentives
which aggravated the problem will only remain
dormant - waiting for the next outbreak, and
enabled by our disinterest.
Like an outbreak, your online security is
easy to ignore 99% of the time, but when something
happens, it’s already too late.
Dashlane is the digital-equivalent of washing
your hands - it’s the simple solution to
keep your passwords and information safe online.
Because, like another outbreak, it’s only
a question of when not if another big hack
will occur.
Except, it’s even better, because, unlike
washing your hands, Dashlane saves you time.
Even if you think you have nothing to hide
or nothing of value online, I still recommend
using Dashlane because it saves you time by
generating and then filling-in your passwords
for you.
You pay one price and get it on all your devices
- Mac, iOS, PC, and Android, then let it start
creating unique and safe passwords for your
accounts.
Of course, holding your passwords is a big
responsibility, and that’s why you should
trust Dashlane, which has been endorsed by
companies like the Wall Street Journal and
featured on the Apple and Google app stores.
Go to the link in the description, Dashlane.com/polymatter
to get a free 30-day trial of Dashlane Premium.
If you like it, use my code “polymatter”
to get 10% off.